uh hunter is here can we call you that
or is that illegal or do you prefer to
be
in some states it is illegal actually
but no
preferably if you're speaking with my
mother she prefers meat but i prefer
hunter
financially for monetary reasons you got
it you know she i think she feels like i
owe her something
you know i mean elaborate like what do
you mean ah you know she's like i
you know i did my business a while ago
right you know you crawled on out yeah
she's like when am i going to get mine
right you know that's how it is usually
yeah trying to collect yeah
collecting yeah see
is that i was going to ask like a super
personal question go ahead yeah i want
you to is that is that something you
deal with you know with your mom is she
like nice animation
when you're taking me somewhere nice
animation
yeah yeah
hey thanks mom yeah good stuff
what relationship is this
yeah the same way
oh man she just references rappers she's
like you know i hear about these rappers
buying hoes birkin bags what are you
gonna do for me hunter yeah she's like i
keep listening to song called laffy
taffy
that's an old cut mom that's odd
if
that's like one thing i've been
exploring again lately is some of the
old from when i was
younger some of before i
got into metal yeah you know what i mean
hell yeah uh i i listened to a lot of ti
did you and bubba sparks
remember uh miss new booty of course
yeah how could you forget have you seen
bubba now nah i haven't checked up bubba
in a minute pull up a picture of boba
sparks you won't even believe if he
doesn't look exactly like fat joe i'm
going to be very upset oh
then my memory serves correctly i got
them mixed up a lot just both bald
basically what happened
start pumping your blood pressure
because this new picture above sparks is
going to send you somewhere
yeah he look he looks like a military
recruiter it's if it's offensive that's
miss new booty dude
i guess now dan is yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's surprising
yeah
damn that's a bit of a disappointment
honestly hey he looks like a grape what
the [ __ ] yeah he's like he's just
straight up
like a i don't know looks like a very
kind of just normal man mm-hmm looks
like every kind of like 48 year old dad
i've met in the midwest yeah going to la
fuentes on a tuesday yeah you know what
i mean look look at him with ed sheeran
that's it oh i thought that the one was
actually what why does ed sheeran look
like a chucky doll in that picture
come on bro
i'm just that's ed sheeran you're
talking about
looking at the crowd everyone's like
yeah that's rude i probably you probably
don't have to
does this did you ever speak to ed
sheeran before no okay i don't think
there's a chance in hell that i ever
speak to ed sheeran so really it's fine
yeah no way you do some big things nah
not big enough rich sharon ed sharon was
in that movie yesterday
um oh
no i didn't watch that one no
it wasn't good i'm just saying i'm just
letting you know yeah he was in lord of
the rings too
it was a game of thrones really
you know yeah game of thrones white guys
the swords it's all the same come on
okay
yeah you're taking it there yeah okay
yeah what's going on are you talking
about my blood pressure my mom's
personal stuff and showing me bubba
sparks ruining that for me and now
[ __ ] i'm back here really uh you're
messing up my vibes this morning yeah
the uh
it was weird because in the game of
thrones uh i think it might have even
been the last season
what did the
divisive uh is that the right word yeah
season of uh television
and it's like we should have a celebrity
cameo how about nobody that sticks out
too much yeah and they choose ed sheeran
yeah i know
i've almost like i've thought about that
like why didn't they just go even
further like how [ __ ] hilarious would
have been if like obama rolled over
in that suit of armor
i'm not even gonna do his voice i was
like i was like you can go go ahead
you want to go there's there's a there's
a line here in this rug he's on that
side i'm on this side
so whatever kind of
obama impression you want to do you
gotta go for it
i think you should try an obama
impression right now
i was getting ready to like actually
move the pawn a little bit in the chest
little chess game that we're playing
right now and i was just like
immediately i was like you lose
as soon as my i pushed the pawn forward
i was like nah
that's done
no but i agree i i
i for some reason i like i knew he was
going to be in that episode
i remember thinking it won't be that bad
like really yeah i just i just figured
like
uh what's his name who uh theon greyjoy
yeah yeah
i figured like all right
you know maybe they could
they could i don't know i could see him
and ed sheeran coexisting in like
you know the type of person in uh game
of thrones so there's no universe where
ed sheeran exists in any kind of fantasy
around yes there he is and you the thing
too is like he even has a musical role
it's kind of like typecasting jack black
to be the wacky rock person yeah yeah
you know yeah but in this they're just
like
what what are you playing
pretty good yeah that's so true and then
he turns around he's just like
[Laughter]
yeah winks the camera yeah exactly
you're gonna hear this in fast and
furious
like ed cut that out
people don't know what that is in this
time
it's just promoting his new album yeah
exactly
yeah he's like this one's gonna be off
love lola bones
i like to imagine you talking i i have a
very skewed inappropriate view of what i
think a lot of british people sound like
where i think it's called language yeah
so basically like russell brand on
laughing guys no russell bryan's kind
yeah more of bait yeah
what if i told you about philosophy yeah
that's kind of his whole stick now yeah
not to obama
hello i'm obama
i could just tell i said even as i was
coming i was like i was like please god
do the british accent do not even mess
up the british accent
it's comical it's satirical oh man
[Music]
anyway speaking of watching things i
watched i finally watched the strength
saying about the johnsons ah yeah
it's a good one yeah do you think ari
intended to play on johnson and the
whole
like
sexual relation between the son and the
dad oh like a like a wee-wee yeah do you
think that was like a cheap joke he just
threw in there to be funny
i may be sublime like maybe yeah yeah i
mean
you know the abuse part is brutal but i
had to like re-watch a lot of scenes
just because
that dude like you could just see his
genius you
right out the gate you watch a lot of
stuff like that
uh what
like incest stuff no no okay no well
it's just when you make a claim like you
could man you see that guy's genius i
was wondering what angle you were taking
oh no i just mean like when you tackle a
narrative like that the way he and the
way you did yeah
that story i mean i just couldn't get
enough yeah exactly i was like why this
is a short film yeah why is this a
feature yeah
i wish this is
going to be a series this should be 12
episodes exactly i need more of this
when's the euphoria-esque
series coming out of this yeah based on
the strange thing about the johnsons
all stylized yeah exactly he grabs his
dad with two hands
we're just completely violating the
point of the film which is like it's not
funny when uh no it's not it's actually
very tragic actually i saw clips of it
and out of context it's very funny yeah
you don't know anything about it i want
to clarify that you don't know about the
then you hear about what it is and
you're like
yeah it's not funny anymore
no it's like a bit sour yeah yeah
no
so to go back to his genius i mean yeah
just like
again like i've never been so bricked up
no um
damn
you